- All y'all rappers out there
think y'all hard
'cause what y'all been through?
Hey, check it out.
♪ It was Friday night chillin' ♪
♪ On my front lawn ♪
♪ Me and my crew,
I had my bathrobe on ♪
♪ Everybody high ♪
♪ Just watched X-Men ♪
♪ Got plenty chicken heads ♪
♪ Ready for sex, men ♪
♪ Busters roll up ♪
♪ They tryin' to talk smack
♪ Don't these [bleep] know ♪
♪ They [bleep] in'
with Tha Mack? ♪
♪ Dude pulled his nine ♪
♪ I knew homies seen us ♪
♪ He pulled two shots ♪
♪ Somehow my penis
got between us ♪
♪ I got shot in the [bleep] ♪
♪ Shot, shot in the [bleep] ♪
♪ But his [bleep]'s
still standing ♪
♪ Shot in the [bleep] ♪
♪ Shot, shot in the [bleep] ♪
♪ I got shot in the [bleep] ♪
♪ But his [bleep]'s
still standing ♪
♪ Went back to my palace fast ♪
♪ Now, I'm the dude walking
'round with a phallus cast ♪
♪ Like Wolverine,
I'm trying to be a loner ♪
♪ But they think a [bleep]
got an adamantium boner ♪
♪ What can I say? ♪
♪ They stil up
on my totem pole ♪
♪ Bitch, get your tongue ring
away from the scrotum hole ♪
♪ Don't know why they love it ♪
♪ But it keeps
the ladies moistening ♪
♪ Gave half the honeys
in the 'hood lead poisoning ♪
♪ Shot in the [bleep],
shot, shot in the [bleep] ♪
♪ I got shot in the [bleep] ♪
♪ But his [bleep]'s
still standing ♪
♪ Shot in the [bleep] ♪
♪ Shot, shot in the [bleep] ♪
♪ I got shot in the [bleep] ♪
♪ But his [bleep]'s
still standing. ♪
- Yo, they shot that fool
in the [bleep]!
- Ahh! Gee, [bleep] man!
- Damn, that hurts.
- What?
Damn no, video over, man.
Video's over.
- No!
- I'm serious, man.
- Damn.